[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
the first thing that probably comes to
mind are Sublime beaches Luxury Resorts
and the rich cultures of people with
very cool tattoos it's as if in this
part of the world except for the
occasional shipwreck nothing ever
happens as if time itself has stopped
and everything on these remote Islands
remains calm homogeneous and peaceful
but wait a minute this is visualpolitik
what if I told you the Pacific is once
again becoming an absolutely crucial
region for the geopolitics of the great
world powers you don't believe me I'll
take a look at this China's foreign
minister is about to meet with 10
Pacific Nations the outcome could have
big ramifications for Australia and yes
okay I know what many of you are
thinking at this very moment who on
Earth would be interested in all those
tiny remote islands that dot the South
Pacific it is true at first glance they
don't seem to have anything interesting
to offer they tend to be rather poor
enclaves highly dependent on tourism and
fishing and to top it all off can be
extremely vulnerable to global warming
well guess what if you think this way
you might actually be very wrong think
about it except for the larger and
wealthier islands of Australia and New
Zealand the rest are tiny Island States
and then there is Papua New Guinea which
is quite big but very poor however do
you know how much total space they
occupy on the world map well pay
attention
[Music]
we are talking about no less than 15 of
the in entire Global surface in other
words all these islands have
jurisdiction over an area that is three
times larger than the entire Continental
surface of the United States and this
gigantic space is these small countries
that have control over any activity that
takes place surprised you shouldn't be
after all if this region wasn't
important why did the former Empire of
Japan put so much effort into taking
over completely during the second world
war the reality is that the little known
South Pacific has an awesome strategic
importance however that did not prevent
this region of the world from falling
into Oblivion when it became independent
between the 1960s and the 1980s but take
note because today the story has changed
again since the beginning of the 21st
century China has been trying to woo
small island States to become not only
its main partner but also its main
economic and political model in fact
that move is exactly what explains news
stories like this one Chinese hospital
ship cruises the South Pacific to spread
influence of course the United States
has started to pay attention and
Australia is already in fifth gear which
after all is why they are a great
Regional power and the region however XI
jinping's regime is offering deals that
are almost impossible to refuse and that
far exceed the West's gamble over recent
decades so the question we can all ask
ourselves is how far does China's
influence in the South Pacific extend
why does this region suddenly seem so
important can Australia and the United
States regain their political dominance
in this remote part of the world in this
video we're going to answer all of these
questions but first you know what I'm
gonna say let's take a look at some
history
[Music]
the dream of the South
I'm sure that unless you live there
apart from the occasional travel
documentary on TV or here on YouTube
most of you have never really stopped to
think about this part of the world many
of you may not even have heard of some
of these countries that lie in the
waters there and you would certainly
never recognize them as having the
slightest political relevance however my
visual politic friends for a long time
these islands were much more than Beach
locations for travel programs and dodgy
reality shows they were strategic
enclaves
the South Pacific is divided into three
different regions on the one hand there
is Polynesia which is the largest region
and extends to Easter Island itself you
know the one with the Big Stone head
monuments that look kind of like me then
there is Micronesia which as its name
suggests has the smallest islands and
finally melanesia which is characterized
because its population tends to be
darker not surprisingly none of these
three regions escaped European
colonialism the first arrival took place
in 1513 the protagonist was the Spanish
explorer and conqueror Vasco Nunez de
baoba for that moment on Dutch German
French and English voyages continue to
follow one after the other in the 18th
century Europeans began to develop
plantations mainly sugar plantations
however the Strategic importance of this
region did not become clear until the
two World Wars of the 20th century it
was then that it became evident that the
South Pacific is a crucial region for
maintaining Australia's connection to
the United States and the rest of Asia
don't forget that Australia is not only
a very important Ally of the United
States it is also a huge repository of
all kinds of Natural Resources however
once World War II ended the South
Pacific ceased to be of interest to the
great Powers the islands gained their
independence and Australia became the
area's police during that time
practically the only relevant movement
was the arrival of a few tourists
however when the day came that the
People's Republic of China set its sight
on the region everything changed think
about it in the event of a conflict
Chinese presence in the area could
prevent the United States from using
Australia as a resupply center for its
operations in the region in other words
by getting a foothold in this region
China could prevent the growing Alliance
that Washington is forging with Canberra
and Tokyo from being effective let's
take a look
[Music]
the Chinese dream
it has already become a familiar story
and all those former colonies of Europe
that are still eminently poor China is
moving like a fish in water to try and
gain advantage on visualpolitik we have
already told you about the growing
presence of the Asian giant in
sub-Saharan Africa well the South
Pacific is no different we are talking
about growing ties that until relatively
recently hardly anyone cared about
however in 2022 there was one piece of
news that set off all of the alarm Bells
I'm sure you all remember it Solomon
Islands China deal in Pacific Stokes
Australian fears exactly China finalized
its first security agreement in the
region with the Solomon Islands which
does not mean that it was set up a
military base in the country but it will
have certain privileges
foreign for example China will be able
to send military personnel and armed
police to secure its project in the
country and it will also have access to
local ports so that its Fleet can
resupply there as you can imagine
Australia's biggest fear is that China
will eventually get around to putting a
military base there that would be less
than 2 000 kilometers that is 1243 miles
from the Australian coast for the time
being the prime minister of the Solomon
Islands has denied this possibility let
me assure you all again there is no
military base nor any other military
facility or institutions in the
agreement and I think that's a very
important point that we continue to
reiterate to the family in the region
Solomon Islands prime minister July
2022. however those assurances there
will be no Chinese military base
reassure no one the agreement has been a
turning point a profound change in the
South Pacific because for the first time
since World War II Australia is seeing a
direct challenge to its Regional
dominance and let's keep in mind that
China has not stopped with the Solomon
Islands in 2022 it signed several
agreements with karibas which believe it
or not as one of the largest exclusive
economic zones in the world meanwhile in
Fiji they are carrying out projects such
as the wanguo Friendship Plaza the
tallest tower in the South Pacific these
are just two examples we even find that
China in addition to mobilizing a
hospital ship is also handing out a lot
of scholarships for students in the
region so the question is what is China
after what does it hope to get in return
for all of this Aid
[Music]
clearly influence but keep in mind we
are not only talking about military ties
such as those being developed with the
Solomon Islands we are also talking
about a political agenda for example the
firm and unwavering support for the
Asian giant in spaces such as the United
Nations you could say that for China it
is a relatively cheap way to win a lot
of votes and mind you we are not only
talking about cooperation or agreements
at a government level many Chinese
companies such as ZTE or Hawaii are
trying to get a foothold in the region
of course wait a minute because not
everyone trusts Beijing in some cases
Chinese activities on these islands are
fueling ethnic and social tensions
corruption intensive fishing by Chinese
fishing vessels and fears about loss of
sovereignty are not making anyone happy
with this Association which is precisely
what explains news stories like this one
Solomon Islands experienced his second
day of protests with attacks on Chinese
businesses and of course China is still
far from winning this race why because
Uncle Sam has finally woken up let's
take a look
[Music]
the red hot competition
not since the second world war has the
South Pacific been in such high demand
following China's Landing now Australia
and the United States have stepped up to
the plit now how do you think they are
doing it well basically by pulling out
the checkbook take a look at this U.S
pledges 210 million dollars to Pacific
Islands to counter China's influence and
not only that in February 2022 U.S
Secretary of State Anthony blinken
visited Fiji it was the first time in 36
years that secretary of state had
traveled here Uncle Sam has also
announced the reopening of embassies in
Tonga and the Solomon Islands in
addition to re-establishing the U.S
agency for International Development in
Fiji but by far the biggest reproachment
took place in Washington where a summit
chaired by President Joe Biden himself
was held in the fall of 2022 and where
the U.S pledged to invest more than 800
million dollars in infrastructure
projects on the other hand we should not
forget that although China has signed
security agreement with the Solomon
Islands the United States has
Association treaties with three
countries in the region the Marshall
Islands the Republic of paulu and the
Federated States of Micronesia thanks to
these agreements the United States can
establish bases and control the access
of third countries to the territorial
Waters of these three countries these
agreements have to be renewed between
this year and next but no doubt this
will be fairly straightforward and then
of course relatively close behind are
the two heavyweights Guam and American
Samoa two territories that are already
under U.S sovereignty with a situation
similar to that of Puerto Rico
in Guam in fact we can find a very
significant military presence about a
quarter of the island is under U.S
military control we are talking about a
naval base and an air base where more
than 6 000 soldiers are deployed and
where we can find Advanced Equipment
such as nuclear submarines or the F-22
the Crown Jewel of the U.S Air Force for
its part Australia an addition was once
again taking relations with all these
small countries seriously has an
important Ace up its sleeve it is still
by far the one that writes the biggest
check take this chart for example as you
can see China has promised a lot of
things but when it comes to putting up
the dough Australia is still way ahead
in other words one way or another no
matter how much progress China has made
the United States and Australia still
have the upper hand be that as it may
this is another one of the many races
that China and the United States are
waging around the world at the moment
but having come this far it's now over
to all of you who do you think will gain
the upper hand in the South Pacific have
you ever thought that this remote region
could be won the international agenda
have you ever imagined yourself sailing
around these idyllic Islands leave us
your thoughts and your comments below
and you know if you found this video
interesting don't forget to like And
subscribe to all of us here on
visualpolitik if you haven't already
done so all the best and I'll see you
next time
[Music]